more than 30 people are dead after
two express trains collided in pakistan
police say one of the trains derailed
and then the other slammed into it
it's not clear what caused the crash
pakistan's prime minister imran khan
has ordered an investigation
twisted metal the remains of two packed
passenger trains
just before dawn one train derailed
falling into the path of another hours
after the crash
rescue teams and local volunteers are
still trying to free trapped passengers
or eight train carriages were destroyed
many passengers are still trapped there
and rescue work only started three hours
after the crash the injured are taken to
the local hospital
where medical workers rush to save the
lives of those pulled from the wreckage
but authorities say the remote location
of the crash
has slowed the rescue effort
you can see that the rescue operation is
going on
soldiers from the military rangers
district administration personnel
and health teams are taking part but the
operation will gain momentum after heavy
machinery arrives here
[Applause]
[Music]
much of pakistan's rail infrastructure
is left over from the british colonial
era
while the cause of this crash is still
unknown
accidents are all too common on these
run-down railways